[Music]
the internet flat classic ad watch
foundation and germany in the team of the
recipient heads germany and the design
of working on open data and picked up
hides
how hearty positive portman the
community is
currently also as the blame for the soundtrack
in the integration active support
community maximilian hudel 15 litters
tutorial academy for jessica i like it
that way to the top of the jumps and
progress work out so it will only be
if you in portraits werheim for open
data de and course
society course a working market with
the work in germany am  market
open up system i spotted this
information
the active policy
but replied
[music]
of course so restrictive sex machine
learning to date
the newspaper
the meeting is client bud spencer
transparency as well as in
china most diets will  beer shown
for friends cancer on
how in the top 20
because of the partnership for use cases
in war and data one to data qua  lity gate
relative to the portraits berlin
industrial countries and important that
may have the national quality
cpm wally is and enemy the mashup article
wismar particle and find of the day
gates is fine the sexy the webby award
the advantages offers better place in
germany for example all  over the world
more wind for the flintstones the
remuneration practice stuttgart stuttgart
live us pictures stuttgart ok much
thinner stuttgart knows in the change
an open beta system application
pasching in he
the enemy is guided in value recognized
as move on the way to take part 1 and
stuttgart ii has checked find of the day
software
dirt 2 in stuttgart
july online marketing offers from the 4th
here you know here our websites on
the instruments window and bed
stuttgart
a little frequented
[music]
playtech something about the community e-
mail
hamburg
[music]
[Music]
political cooperation of data
business volker keller and wise to
important to talk  about that made in
germany
september federal returning officer and sincerely
[music]
almost half at city until you the
costs so a cd player with devil
back end web federal railway manages the
department licensed under way of the
ancients 2
so nice with think it's ok to life
balance
who defends format but man built a
tutor i have in alps a wolf in the web
plaster support the picture of the wall
along the event what if he people
open data analytics open data network
bebo from the nba title working with most
important for the agency federal electoral officer
stolen and weight
of the third
exchange of words white horses all gone because
you know the course 92 website at the mad sin
city primitive which way with the future
of work together to be a part of the
republic
[music]
ok
for the source a t digital tv
more  to prepare 62 thorsten projects is
wikipedia fbk center storage on site 10
it's cool up with the dips according to
wikipedia people
the database and public domain wik
ipedia article exactly gnarly enemy on board how
the data data object from account data
object to object 16 a database
and when love takes over two days a week
[music]
download
matthias bartl endpoint however web
surfing
2 vvg export via web services germany
stuttgart accidents wm-  ok here in
kreuzberg
here in germany
[music]
so what you tube and ask the state
[applause]
[music]
wow
data service possible to me too late
extended support and service audience
hesse estate swansea is just motive a
using the date  on what i am looking at
the head and simple things can be found
at web data is more often than its
latest figures humans mistakes the
faithful would have demanded advertising public
spaces lie with pressure here express
in a technology since solution
day began which is now how producing
away vortex leitwerk surveys
measuring anything about people because
as at once
[Music]
kontakt
[Ap  cheers]